and i turn to my right right now and i
see not only a super bowl champion i see
a walter payton man of the year award
winner and i'm also genuinely concerned
quite frankly about my best dad ever
title that's right here on the desk he
is andrew whitworth
back here on the rich eisen show good to
see you sir you too rich man it's
awesome to be back here in studio man
thank you i appreciate that i know
you're eyeing my best dad ever sign i
like that i thought that was pretty cool
right i appreciate that i got it from my
kids um but you know i'm i'm a little um
jittery right now with you here on this
front because
uh the video i saw of you sitting on the
turf
and you sitting your kids down
and telling them dad just played his
last game as the confetti's coming down
you're in your uniform
holy cow man that one blew me away
andrew whitworth that was a special
moment it was a cool opportunity right
there where i had all for him for just a
second and i realized hey i got this
little moment i can kind of just sit
with them and and share
kind of what was on my heart and what i
was feeling and they kind of knew it was
coming sure um
but they love football they love being a
part of the rams organization they've
you know they're such big fans of
everybody there and they consider
everyone family so i knew it was a good
time to sit down with them and just let
them understand that this is probably it
for me and
we can still be fans and we can still be
involved but this is kind of the end of
that road for me and i wanted them to
know i was committing to to that did
they
because i i know my kids too like with
confetti coming down the lights the
music the game had just ended did they
really understand what you were telling
them some of them even the younger ones
really understand what dad was actually
expressing you know i think catherine
was probably more interested in hitting
me with the confetti
yeah so that was probably the only thing
she's seven she has right so that's the
only thing she really cared about the
moment but no she listened but the boys
really and sarah my oldest daughter um
i think for them it's an emotional
roller coaster because they've kind of
gone through the age of
i would say like six to nine it's like
you're they're excited and every game so
much fun
and then all of a sudden now you know 11
11 and 10
they start kind of realizing like this
game takes a toll on dad and they see
kind of the injuries and they see some
of those things and i think it starts to
make them be a little nervous and scared
throughout the game and they lose a
little bit of the fun part
just because they're a little bit
concerned about dad being okay every
time he comes home yeah and and i think
that is
part of the brady conversation that i
think a lot of people are missing yeah
that they just think well he just loves
the game too damn much or he's so good
of course he's going to keep playing
and um
you gotta
factor that in right i mean you really
do i mean it starts to be a little like
i know my oldest daughter sarah got to
the point where she didn't even like to
even watch anymore she would kind of sit
in the back of the suite and not pay
attention because i think for her it
just became like i just want especially
after last year with me tearing my pcl
and mcl and her kind of seeing that
battle and the struggle it was to come
back like you're getting cards yeah
getting carded off and i think that's
always been kind of something that's
told on her and so it's gotten less fun
to be at the games and more just she
wants the rams to win and me to be okay
um so i think you know it's one of those
things look i've accomplished a lot of
things in this game i've had a lot of
great opportunities had a ton of cool
relationships and i can still be
involved in different ways and and not
have to go out there and be on the field
necessarily uh putting myself at risk so
what what what's the first thing you did
knowing you don't have to be ready for a
season give me give me the give me the
first thing you're like i'll screw it
i'm gonna do this uh you know what i was
actually just talking to gio bernard a
former teammate of mine in cincinnati
with tampa the last couple years and he
was saying you know uh just sending me
kind of congratulations for retiring and
he goes but i know you you're a maniac
you probably worked out today already
and i said i did actually i said oh yeah
i'm sitting i'm getting after it i've
been kind of training trying to lose
some weight and
diets and probably better than i ever
have
yeah you know i just okay it's one of
those things you got to find something
new to be passionate about so i'm trying
to get in shape and get to the point
where i can run around play with the
kids have some fun and feel a little
better about my body and where i'm at so
obviously taking some weight off the
joints and a little less pressure is
going to be helpful with that okay all
right i'm impressed by that yeah you
know we got to work normally i just
think you would just be like loaded up
like i've seen some guys are just loaded
up just the hell with it you know well
you know i want to get on the golf
course i want to improve the swing rich
i got to get some you know a lot of body
in the way when you're no lineman you're
six seven 340 it's a long way down to
the ground without clubs right so where
what's our game looking like what do we
got here you know we're getting down
there you know probably four or five
index something like that so oh yeah so
i'm but i'm gonna i'm gonna go in low
this year i'm shooting for the zero this
year that's like i'm putting it out
there that's my goal i'm shooting for
the zero i'm going scratch okay but by
the way i'm very impressed another ram
uh of note who sat in this chair uh
marshall falk will not tell his handicap
in person or out loud he just just means
he's a good better you know because he
wants to set the handicap on the right
day yeah he wants the candy he wants the
candy and he doesn't want to give out
any uh any information so uh what's the
longest you can hit a golf ball like
what do you got uh well i mean obviously
with my size and strength hitting it a
long ways is not really an issue i can
hit it up there with some of the big you
know drivers on tour probably but uh
doesn't mean i hit it straight you know
they might hit it nine out of ten ten
times like that i hit it two out of ten
times like that well you just named
bryson dechambeau's game to it's a t
pretty much right there yeah
that's right i mean i like getting out
of the way all right i prefer the rough
to the fairway so three what three bills
every time oh yeah oh yeah with a driver
for sure yeah
didn't even hesitate oh yeah okay oh
yeah easy no i mean uh for instance sam
burns is a is a friend he plays on tour
he's a tremendous player young guy and
i've played with him before and i mean i
can get close sometimes to his drives i
mean i'll be up there with him but yeah
i mean obviously i can't hit it
consistently like those guys so i got a
lot of masks get out of the way so we
gotta get leaned out we gotta get ready
to go i gotta dial it in man i'm
attacking the senior tour or something
you know what what's out there very good
andrew whitworth here unrealistic you
know expectation but let's do it
who can who can say no i mean look at
that i mean honestly when you guys went
through like a three-game losing streak
this year everybody thought rams are
toast
now look at you now look at you right
now that's right you know are you coming
for romo right now is what you're doing
uh no i mean you know i probably got
some years to go before that but i'm
going to put in the work and we'll see
where we end up
that's a yes that's the yes
okay very good andrew whitworth here on
the rich eisen show uh what now what
what do you want to do you said you want
to be part of the game still how do you
want to be part like give me your wish
list right now
man you know what i just to me it's like
i love the game of football i'm not one
of those guys that's ever had a dream to
run a business or do this other thing
that they want to get into when they got
done with football i've always want to
be involved some way some form some
fashion and so
it's really uh a cool thing in the sense
that i got a lot of options because of a
lot of the things that i've gotten to do
in my career and be a part of and be
successful at so it's really trying to
figure out is that you know do i want to
attack like trying to find a way to be
in tv and media or do i want to stay
involved in some way with the rams or
other organizations i mean i've had a
lot of
fun people reach out coaches gm stuff
like that just what i want to do and
asking me that question and then also
had some opportunities to talk to some
networks so
i'll uh i'm going to dive into that and
try and figure out what i really think
i'll be the most passionate about i
think that's really important to me
because
i don't ever want to do anything that
i'm half-hearted about or i don't really
i'm not sure i want to be where i am and
so i want to make sure it's something i
can kind of dive into be passionate
about and want to be great at it
coaching is that
i don't think coaching is going on the
table why is that um
i think really it would be the opposite
of what i'm trying to do right now and
that is
for me i think coaches work an extreme
amount of hours i mean i think that that
would kind of take away from what i
would want to accomplish being able to
really do what i've done throughout my
career and devote myself the way i have
i think that takes me away a little bit
more for my family and
i think it's tough i mean i have so much
respect for coaches that the time it
takes for them to do their job and
really the stress and and the efforts
and all those things and then also to be
away from the family the way they are at
certain times that's that's a tough deal
and i got a ton of respect for them and
the way they're able to do it so front
office is that what you were saying yeah
i mean something like that along that
line would be something i'd be very
interested in and like roster building
like that yeah i mean i've always that's
always been a passion about me i've
loved like going around the building
when i've played i mean i go around the
building and have those conversations
with everybody there from from training
staffs to
scouting departments to the gm's and all
that i've always kind of made sure i
made my way on the building and you know
kind of searched out how all that works
and what their mindset is how they get
to those things i've always loved it
i've always liked to kind of study teams
and rosters and who i think is going to
be successful year in year out and so
i think for me that's a lot of fun and
it's really cool to think of piecing
those things together and
it'd be something i'd be interested in
for sure well i mean
you look you should just call games be
an analyst call games because you play
it right you're going to get a pay raise
you see what's going on right now it's
unbelievable it really is you could make
i mean romo is making more in one year
than i think he did um in like two or
three when he was a quarterback that's
wow that's right that industry has
changed so much and not only that it's
just growing so much and there's gonna
be so many different things going on
especially with what amazon's done and
all the different platforms they'll have
and so
i think it's uh it's one of those things
that you know that industry and all the
different networks are growing and
getting bigger and there's all these
people getting different shows so right
yeah i mean that's fun to look at and
see that landscape and see where you
might get fit in it and so i think for
me it's trying to figure out which one i
think i'd really want to be a part of
and be passionate about doing okay uh
andrew whitworth here on the rich eisen
show so um von miller just signed with
the bills
give me some insight on what he did with
aaron donald because we
i just mentioned i started this
conversation with you about you know how
nfl films picked up your conversation
with your family on the ground on the
turf with the confetti coming down you
told him that you're retiring
that you heard um donald tell miller
that
what he meant to aaron donald and kind
of unlocked did he unlock something a
little bit in donald that or inspire
something in donald that you hadn't seen
prior i think really
to me what i saw aaron really do is he
embraced his voice some as our last half
the season went on and i thought that
was interesting because he's always been
a guy who's
you know without question the hardest
working guy i've ever seen ever been
around especially with that kind of
talent i thought it was so rare when you
match his talent was it with his work
ethic it was second to nobody but to see
him start to use his voice and to start
kind of uh bringing guys along with him
and kind of challenging people to play
better challenging people to play up to
an expectation that his defense should
have almost taken that ownership of like
not only am i the best player on the
planet but i'm going to be one of the
best leaders on the planet too
i thought that was a massive step for
aaron donald and really really something
that everyone just been waiting for they
all look up to him so much
but he's never been a real vocal guy and
he really took on that role and i think
vaughn kind of inspired him to be that
way to be like hey man you're the
greatest player on the planet like if
you want me to do something better tell
me you know and and so i think aaron
really took that role on and i think it
was a massive factor for how they played
in the playoffs and really the last part
of the season uh was really aaron taking
that next step i think all great players
that played for a long time you find
different ways to grow and i think for
aaron donald he found a way to grow with
his voice and being vocal and
challenging his guys to step up and play
better so vaughn basically told aaron
feel free to challenge me yeah feel free
to like use your voice to challenge your
teammates and uh like we all want to
hear from you you know i think sometimes
you think like i don't want to be the
cheesy guy that tells people what to do
or tries to command people to do
something a certain way when i don't
maybe i hold myself to such a high
regard sometimes i forget that i set the
standard all the time right and so i
think for him it was almost just having
those conversations with vaughn just
playing like hey man it's playoff time
let's play it elite because we are elite
but let's also challenge the guys around
us to play that way and i think it
really freed him up to be like you know
what there's nothing wrong with me
challenging guys around me like i don't
have to say because i didn't get four
sacks today and because people don't
think i'm the defensive mvp or whatever
they're having this argument
following one short of being the
defensive mvp doesn't mean i can't talk
and i can't speak up and challenge guys
around me and i think him almost having
that freedom to say it's okay to
challenge guys it's okay to step up and
be vocal and say hey this is how we
expect to do it and i think he really
started to do that and you saw just all
those guys like man we've been waiting
for this and they loved it and they and
they responded to it so if his baseline
or his base
or his floor for the lack of a better
phrase
was what it was when von miller came in
and said hey this is a way you can do it
and then we saw what that meant for
donald in some of the ways that he was
literally closing games like a closer in
baseball like strike three game over
drive home safely
it's frightening that his base
or floor now is doing what he just did
coming back after winning a super bowl
that's downright frightening it really
is if you look at leadership i mean
there's a lot of different ways that you
can talk about great players and leaders
right and some of them perform really
well and then they just kind of are who
they are and they lead by example and
people are like oh man if i could be
like this guy you know i'd be a good
football player or i'd be good at
whatever sport or business we're talking
about but then eventually there's these
next steps where you start to make
other leaders out of people because you
challenge them or you kind of show them
a way to become a leader and then
there's like hey i make all the people
around me better
also and so i think what aaron donald
really did is he went from one of the
greatest defensive players
on the planet and probably ever in the
history of the game
to now not only that but i can also make
the guys around me play better than they
are right now and they can find a new
level for themselves because i'm the
person of all people that can challenge
them to chase that and i think that
really just is going to be something
i'll be interested this year
to see him build off of that and how
much he'll mean for his group and the
people who play defense with him
having him as their vocal leader and not
just their example leader so he's coming
back right i mean again and i hesitate
to ask you that question because i know
you didn't want anybody talking for you
while you had a decision to make over
the last few weeks even though you
seemed like you made it within seconds
of the super bowl ending but is your
sense that he's
uh i would think so i mean i you know
watching him work and already knowing
the way he's training right now and
preparing himself i would think he'll
come back i mean obviously i think
there's things to work out there but um
i think for him you know chasing another
one uh is worth it i mean i would love
to see him do it i mean i'd be sad to
see him step away from it just because i
mean like i said i think he's just
continuing to write a legacy of being
one of the deaf you know the best
defensive players ever play this game so
um i would love to see him to keep doing
it and they got such a great roster i
mean they got a lot of really good
football players coming back so
they definitely have as good a chance as
anybody you just said they not we
it's over well i mean i'm not playing if
i'm not wearing the helmet
you know impressive you know that was
impressive andrew andrew whitworth here
a few more minutes left before we send
him to the golf course so we just
discussed about how uh
donald has progressed and exploded from
already a level of being terrific and
spectacular and now we'll see what
happens with uh the confidence that
comes with being a super bowl champion
how do you think stafford how do you
think matthew stafford will now
maybe operate in another way or
with a different twist now that
all the questions
they have been answered so emphatically
so what do you think he's going to look
like now with a ring on his finger and
that on his resume do you think
you know i think it's it's one of those
things that kind of takes a little bit
of the pressure off and now it's uh you
look at this last year i mean what a
tough year that had to be for him i mean
having been someone who left cincinnati
after 11 years and went through the
experience of changing your whole life
in one year your family everything him
and kelly are in the same situation i
mean they have you know four little
girls and you know moved their entire
family to l.a
and
came to all kinds of expectations a
really good football team like an
environment where you were the best
player on your team for a really long
time and everyone used that as an excuse
of hey you know what y'all lose but you
just don't have any help so it's like
all right now you're with this really
good football team really good culture
like you there's no question you should
just win all the time
i mean
people can say that you can draw it up
on paper but that's not easy to do and
so he had to go through a wild year of
expectation and pressure and all right
if you're really who you are and who you
say you are and people say you are then
you should be winning with this team
and you think about it like the pressure
that takes to be expected to do
something not have the chance to just
prove it is a whole lot different and to
do it and then make it all the way and
perform
maybe the best of your career
in the last three or four games of the
season
and win the super bowl
um i would imagine there's a different
swagger that matthew stafford number
nine steps on the field with comes
september in his first game that says i
know who i am
and i'm excited to build off of it with
the guys i already know and i'm already
comfortable in this system uh i'll be
i'll be shocked to see him not play out
of his mind next year that is exciting
it really is because again um the way
that your
your team you guys finished the season
right
and um the way that it ended where you
didn't get that two spot
right you did wind up
waxing arizona and then we saw you know
kyler murray wanting his contract now i
mean the fallout of that loss was
significant for that organization you
got hurt in that one so you didn't play
against tampa you had to be out of your
mind watching that with no
control over it right but stafford
making that throw to cup at the end
honestly was just a moment that you'll
look back along with his no look pass to
cup in the super bowl those are the two
throws that kind of
changed everything and he was the one
who he was the one who delivered that
cup obviously being on the back end of
it too
yeah
there's no doubt i think yeah i think i
was in the fetal position most of the
game like a closet
yeah uh you know it was great the first
half i was excited running around the
house and then i spent the last you know
probably
20 minutes of the game just hiding in
the closet somewhere it's like telling
my wife to text me right what if that
was your retirement exactly and so yeah
it was wild for for that victory to
happen and then the way he performed in
the san fran game the last part last
half of the game to win the nfc
championship and then the super bowl i
mean
uh you know it's really unbelievable you
really draw up the super bowl and you
say listen you know if you told me hey
at one point in the game you're gonna
have your third tight end in the game
who's really played might be five snaps
all season
uh you're gonna only have cooper cup and
then
you know lose odell
and then have the opportunity where van
jefferson's playing an injured injured
knee that he ended up you know have to
get taken care of this offseason and
then
you know benny skoe is out there playing
uh skronik is playing special teams and
now he's going to play a lot of receiver
and how about weddle with his with his
weddings
it's like in matt to matthew to go out
there and orchestrate the drive he did
and
in that moment
um
is unbelievable with really their
defense the whole plan was to take
cooper cup out of the game and to find
ways to find him and then also get the
ball to other guys in that group to just
drive it down the field in six and a
half minutes to win a game is like i
said i think there's a different
demeanor and attitude that matthew walks
out with next year and says all right i
just did that in the biggest moment of
my life
uh now it's time to just show who i am
and to continue to build the legacy of
what a great player i am andrew
whitworth thanks for coming here greatly
appreciate it i just uh want you to know
that if you wind up having the best
round of your life don't forget where
you were
earlier in the day
and if you play poorly um um i i don't
remember this conversation how does that
sound exactly all credit to the rich
eisen show if i play well today
and uh i forgot where i was before i
started my round if not welcome to the
media
if that's your endeavor you so choose
that's exactly in a nutshell credit
where it's not really due
totally ignoring it when you actually
should take responsibility that's the
way you
i'm here for it thank you for that what
i'm saying i'm here for you good to see
you andrew congrats on everything for
you and your family so well deserved i
couldn't be more happy for you i
appreciate it it's an honor you got it
thank you for even saying that hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here